You came here looking for a tracker
Who...or what...am I tracking?
That´s a big one!
Before we leave this island, we are going to bring that ape down.
We are all gonna die together out here.
You shouldn´t have come here.
Kong Skull Island, Rated PG 13
Experience it in an IMAX March 10th
It´s a survey job. Just chopper them in and out.
It´ll be a joyride.
You are going to tell me everything I don´t know
or I´m gonna blow your head off.
This planet doesn´t belong to us.
Ancient species owned this Earth long before mankind.
I spent 30 years trying to prove the truth.
Monsters exist.
You don´t go into someone´s house, unless you are picking a fight
What you're looking at...it's a monster
from some bygone era
It's time to sell that man
it's King!